this video is sponsored by the
interactive math and science learning
platform brilliant
for millions of years they slept
then suddenly their eyes began to open
surrounding each of them was a small
opaque chamber filled with clear
yellowish liquid a tube was connected to
each of their stomachs they could only
see a soft glimmering light through the
chamber's casing
deep disorientation set in crying echoed
out of every chamber
they soon began to thrash inside pushing
and breaking their way out
side was a vast structure that was
somehow both familiar and foreign to
them long hauls led to open foyers and
sectioned off rooms there was no one
else anywhere exterior windows revealed
darkness in all directions clusters of
stars and planets appeared to be moving
slowly past them in the distance
where were they they wondered
where do they come from where were they
going
the group was small there were 100 of
them it was a diverse group of 50 males
and 50 females covering a wide spectrum
of physical qualities and character
traits they all seem to awake with the
same relative ability of language and
comprehension and they all seem to
possess the same innate knowledge they
knew what certain things were and they
knew the words for those things they
knew they were people with bodies and
minds and they knew how to use those
bodies and Minds though it required lots
of improvising and innovation
right away they began to explore the
structure it was massive primarily made
of metal but the metal was mostly
covered with other kinds of materials
and casings there were multiple levels
each containing long open hallways
separating large sealed off sections
each section contained different
environmental conditions with different
self-sustaining ecosystems there was
water plants and animals in each
the group soon began to call the
structure the space station
but with millions of years of unending
sleep and millions of memories formed in
dreams no one knew what the reality was
of their past reality and dreams blurred
together
consequently no one knew their origins
or purpose
it was as if they were expected to
remember
soon various myths and stories began to
form around vague memories many opinions
and theories developed about their
Origins their purpose and their future
the group consensus became that they and
the space station were created by gods
they were selected by the gods and put
on the space station with their purpose
being to obey them and in doing so the
space station would continue moving
As Time passed this belief went through
many changes and broke off into many
different versions some individuals
began to believe that there was only one
God they simply needed to trust in and
follow his guidance following the
program and autopilot system set by him
if they did they would be rewarded and
arrive at their final destination where
everything would finally make sense
years and years would go by social
structure would develop and Advance on
the space station children were born
generations of families passed and yet
still there was no arrival in sight
more questions began to stack on top of
the prior still unanswered ones
during a group-wide meeting regularly
held in the Space Station's Central room
to discuss updates concerns plans hopes
and anything else one younger member
came forward and brought fully into
question the group's beliefs why did we
awake when we did if there is nowhere to
go and nothing to do she said why did
God put us here and program our guidance
system in this way why would we be
awoken to suffer and die for nothing
years and years of nothing but sickness
infighting death and loss the terrible
oscillation between boredom and anxiety
the Deep sense of cosmic isolation in a
vast Darkness inhabited by no one else
trapped in here alone
there was a long Silence with no direct
response to follow
soon the group became consumed by this
line of questioning and doubting they
began to thrash at their surroundings
pushing things open and breaking things
down they took everything apart and dug
into every layer every component every
mechanism of the space station looking
for answers
after years and years of doing this they
understood how the space station worked
why it worked the way it worked but
beyond that still nothing
an understanding of how did not bring
them any closer to a why
it all appeared mechanical and personal
there is no God we have killed him a 20
year old individual named nihil said
during a meeting
if we don't know where we are going if
we are going nowhere or even if we are
going somewhere but for a reason that
has nothing to do with us why are we
continuing at all why keep bringing more
people into this why keep striving and
trying and suffering
why not just stop
we can end it now
there was a long silence
then another individual came forward it
was an older man in his 50s named Lux
who had been crucially important in the
Space Station's recent coordination and
sustainment of social and political
structures he had one of the largest
families on the space station and was
highly respected though often very quiet
when he came forward everyone was silent
with anticipation
perhaps we were merely put on the space
station by someone or something to
continue life in the cosmos to survive
but for what nihil interjected surely
there was some reason but a reason in
terms of a cause is different than the
kind of reason you're looking for that
we've all been looking for but maybe
that's just not the kind of Reason we'll
ever find and the wrong reason to
continue looking for
perhaps the question isn't for what
reason or where are we going but how do
we meaningfully keep going without any
reason
in all likelihood we are aimless out
here autopilot is no pilot we have no
idea where we are going or why we appear
to have been put here by someone or
something that we have no memory of or
access to
perhaps it cared about us once perhaps
it didn't perhaps it did but didn't know
any better
regardless it doesn't seem to know us
now and it doesn't seem like we'll ever
know it or them
maybe we simply woke up too soon or too
late maybe you thought we would remember
or know maybe they didn't know
themselves
but look around The Grand Design of the
ship of us
maybe it wasn't God but God was at
something impressive we have formed
social unions in order families
friendships we've been able to create to
love to laugh to experience and hope all
on our own
and every day the stars outside our
Windows twinkle with the beauty and
mystery that transport us back to the
state of all we experienced in those
early days when we first awoke
maybe we need to hope for something else
to keep going
but we don't need anything else to keep
going
[Music]
this video was sponsored by brilliant
ever since Sam was a kid he always loved
learning about the inner workings of
things he loved big Concepts in science
and technology but both in and outside
of school he always seemed to have a
hard time focusing and engaging and
learning by the time he was a young
adult Sam wanted to pursue a career in
computer science but felt like he was
behind because of this problem then at
20 years old everything changed in just
six months Sam suddenly learned more
about computer science technology and
science in general than he had in his
entire life prior he learned about the
Core Concepts behind AI neural networks
and machine learning and he developed a
strong Proficiency in programming he was
able to do this by using brilliant.org
Sam realized that he needed a way to
interact with visualize and play with
various problems and models in order to
feel engaged and more easily learn new
information and that's exactly what
brilliant does by providing interactive
and effective courses in math science
and computer science brilliant helped
eliminate the barriers for Sam and made
easy for him to actually engage in and
Excel at a career in technology his
favorite course was introduction to
neural networks where he learned about
all the fascinating ways neural networks
work through interactive games puzzles
and visualization simulations
demonstrating how computers C learn and
predict he also loved the course
scientific thinking to help him to think
and understand the world from a deeper
more scientific perspective of course
Sam is Not Unusual if you're also
someone who wants to understand and
Excel at the subjects that shape our
understanding of the world and the
future of civilization in a fun
interactive and effective way brilliant
is for you as well go to brilliant.org
pursuit of Wonder or click the link in
the description to sign up for your free
30-day trial the first 200 people who do
will also receive 20 off their annual
premium membership
and of course as always thank you so
much for watching in general and see you
next video
[Music]
foreign